Parasites have a bad reputation - but is it really fair to fear these small parasites? Okay,
Yes - and if you do not think so, here are the reasons why these horrible creatures deserve to be avoided
At all costs!
As if you need another reason to hate mosquitoes - when the mosquito bites the human they can leave the larvae
Of parasitic worm Filaria. These worms live and grow in our bodies, sometimes you need
For years to mature full puberty, skin rash and sores are not only obvious. Years
Later, worms work together to block the blood vessels of the lymphatic system, creating accumulation
Of fluids that lead to diseases such as elephant disease. It is one of the main causes of disability
In the world
Another worm worth the ball is the pin. Pork eggs are often eaten because
The hands are dirty or contaminated. Leading to the reduction of eggs and maturity in the intestines where the worm
Get out of the anus to put a new batch of eggs on the surrounding skin. Making the anus area
Asha for them! This causes severe itching, often leading to hands or nails to be contaminated again,
Which can eventually make it into your mouth again, resulting in a reboot cycle. You feel itching in your ass?
Do yourself a favor and wash those hands and nails!
On the other side of the body, live pubic lice - sometimes called "crab" for some reason
It is not uncommon to find these trivial creatures in eyebrows, beard or even eyelashes.
Itching is an allergic reaction to lice lice, and it needs treatment with medication
Or shaving to get rid of them. Of course, abstinence works well
As a precautionary measure, along with non-engagement underwear with other people.
Some parasites are particular to marine animals, but eventually come to humans through good in
Our eyes? Necrotic nematodes infect humans after eating raw or poorly cooked fish - such as
Sushi - which contains the larvae. The worms penetrate our intestinal wall and cause
Abdominal pain, nausea and vomiting. But, no one really wins, because nematodes can not
Mature into the human intestines and eventually die.
Tongue is another marine parasite. Lent eat the tongue
Fish appropriate and chew off the fish tongue, to cling to its place. Here they stay
They feed on the fish's blood, while at the same time their offspring mate and spread
Ocean
Finally, Cordyceps is a wonderful fungus known for creating zombie ants.
The fungi control the body around the ants and the mind, making it leave the colony and begin climbing
The upward to the temperature and humidity are more ideal. Then the ant bite on the leg or leaves
Which leads to the imprisonment of the fungus until he dies. At this point, the mushrooms rush through
Head ants and spread out.
Can these parasites ever affect humans? For everyone, hope not!
Our friends at James Cook University helped us to put this terrifying list of parasites together,
With special help from the world of parasites Dr. Kate Hatson. JCU is one of the leading institutes in the world
In focus on the tropics with the opportunity to study in various
Environmental areas are unmatched by any university in the world. I studied there for a while
Classroom abroad! If you want to learn more, visit the university website jcu.edu.au
- link in description! You can check out Dr. Kate Hatson's amazing well at marineparasites.com.
Subscribe to the channel to receive more scientific videos weekly.